Cuando pensamos en África nos resulta
difícil escapar de dos ideas
preconcebidas, por un lado que África es
un continente condenado a la pobreza, una
tierra de enfermedades, hambre y desgracias,
muchas desgracias. Por otro, solemos ver
África como un único territorio
integrado, donde la suerte de unos
está ligada a la de otros. A nuestros
ojos, más que un continente, África
da la sensación de ser simplemente un
pequeño país, y, desde luego, pocas veces
nos damos cuenta de su colosal
dimensión. Porque amigos,
África es tan grande como toda Europa,
Estados Unidos, India, China y Argentina
juntas así que dicho esto ya podéis
imaginar lo diverso que resulta este
territorio.
Bien, pues en línea con estas ideas, en
el año 2010 The Economist calificó a África como
el continente sin esperanza
pero como pasa tantas veces los
pronósticos fallaron por completo.
- " Es el día de la marmota; - sigue siendo sólo
una vez al año, ¿no?".
Desde que comenzó
el nuevo siglo
África ha vivido un auténtico despegue,
sobre todo los países más pobres.
Así, si nos fijamos en los 46
países que conforman el África
Subsahariana, sin contar Sudáfrica,
observamos que entre el 2000 y el 2015
registraron un crecimiento económico
anual del 6,2 por ciento, lo que supone,
por ejemplo, más del doble que el
crecimiento registrado por
Latinoamérica.
De hecho sin ir más lejos, en 2015, cinco
de las diez economías que más
crecieron del mundo fueron africanas:
Costa de Marfil, Etiopía, Tanzania, Ruanda y la
República Democrática del Congo.
Todas ellas tuvieron crecimientos por
encima del 7%.
- "La República Democrática
del Congo se encuentra entre los 10
países del mundo mejor valorados por
sus reformas.
Por ejemplo, sólo en 2014 se crearon
más de 7.000 empresas en el país".
Y claro, todo este crecimiento tiene
consecuencias sociales. Como vimos en un
pasado vídeo sobre la pobreza en el
mundo, desde el 2000 la esperanza de vida
en África ha sumado ocho años, la
mortalidad infantil se ha reducido casi
a la mitad,
lo mismo ocurrió con el hambre, y con
carácter general la pobreza extrema ha
pasado de tener una incidencia del 58%
de la población en 1999, al 35%
hoy en día.
Es verdad que aún hay más
de 420 millones de personas sumidas en
la más absoluta
miseria, lo que es trágico, pero por
fortuna las perspectivas son bastante
positivas y os aseguro que esa zona del
mundo está llamada a jugar un papel muy
relevante en este siglo,
- "Su clase media es la que más está
creciendo del mundo,
el hecho es que África ya no está
emergiendo, está aquí, ahora".
África se está urbanizando a gran
velocidad, lo que favorece la prestación
de servicios públicos y las economías
de escala.
Pronto encontraremos muchas de las
megápolis del mundo en este continente.
Quién sabe, tal vez en unas pocas
décadas Lagos, Nairobi o Accra se
conviertan en la nueva Shanghái.
En Nairobi se está construyendo el que
está llamado a ser el rascacielos más
alto de áfrica, las torres Hass. En Accra, la
capital de Ghana, han construido seis
centros comerciales en sólo seis años,
algo que no sería sorprendente si no
tenemos en cuenta que antes sólo había
uno.
Además, la inversión extranjera directa
ha crecido con fuerza en los últimos
años y ya casi la mitad de toda ella
se concentra en sectores que nada
tienen que ver con los recursos
naturales, porque ese es otro factor
clave, aún con dificultades
muchos de los países africanos están
logrando construir economías cada vez
más complejas. Son los llamados leones
africanos.
Kenia, Uganda, Tanzania, Mozambique, Zambia...
Son muchos los países africanos que
avanzan rápido y de todos ellos
hablaremos de forma específica en el
futuro, pero hoy nos vamos a centrar en
los siguientes casos, porque nos parecen
particularmente relevantes.
Este es un país pequeñito, de apenas 12
millones de habitantes y sin salida al
mar. Aún es muy pobre,  pero desde el año
2001 ha registrado un crecimiento anual
de casi el 9 por ciento y, atención,
hablamos de un país sin petróleo ni
recursos naturales destacados ¿cómo lo ha
conseguido?
Pues fundamentalmente apostando por
favorecer la creación de empresas.
De esta forma, Ruanda es, según el
informe Doing Business del 2016, el
segundo país del África Subsahariana
donde más fácil resulta hacer negocios,
y también es el cuarto de la zona en el
ranking de libertad económica.
¿Casualidad?
Ahora nos estamos fijando en las
ciudades medianas,
si están bien organizadas, y pones todo
lo que se necesita y buenas conexiones,
muy probablemente crecerán".
Gracias a ello, casi la totalidad los
niños cursan educación primaria y
el 98% de los ruandeses tienen ya
acceso a la sanidad, lo que ha supuesto,
por ejemplo, que la mortalidad infantil
caiga un 60 por ciento, y que el sida y
la malaria hayan retrocedido de forma
impresionante.
Por cierto, Paul Kagamé, su presidente,
se declara  discípulo de Lee Kuan Yew,
el legendario líder de Singapur, del
cual os hablamos recientemente.
En este caso hablamos de un país mucho
más grande, de casi 100 millones de
habitantes, y donde por desgracia aún
cerca de 20 millones de personas tienen
problemas nutricionales.
Sin embargo, las cosas están cambiando
velozmente y hoy su capital, Addis Abeba,
es una sucesión de obras.
De hecho, hace algo menos de un año, se
inauguró aquí el primer tren ligero de
toda el África Subsahariana. Y no es para
menos, porque en los últimos 10 años
Etiopía ha sido el país de África que
más ha crecido. Su economía se ha
multiplicado por cinco en este periodo y
el crecimiento del pib real ha superado
el 10% cada año.
- "El país que en la
década de los 80 fuese símbolo
mundial de la pobreza y el hambre, hoy
exhibe las tasas de crecimiento más
altas del África Subsahariana.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo lo han conseguido?
Pues apostando por ser más atractivos que
sus vecinos para la inversión
extranjera.
Así, el país se ha fijado como prioridad
tener un marco macroeconómico estable y
establecer un marco fiscal atractivo.
Por ejemplo las importaciones de bienes de
capital no tienen que pagar ningún
arancel y no se aplica  tampoco ningún
impuesto sobre los beneficios durante
los primeros años de actividad.
Parece sensato ¿verdad?
No podíamos contemplar esta selección
sin este país que precisamente celebra
en 2016 el 50 aniversario de su
independencia. Botsuana ha sido con mucho el
caso de mayor éxito económico de
África, e incluso es uno de los casos de
más éxito a nivel global. Cuando se
independizó en 1966 era uno de los 10
países más pobres del planeta.
Y por si esto no fuese suficiente
obstáculo, el país ha padecido desde
entonces graves problemas de sequía y,
además, ha sido el segundo más afectado
por el VIH.
A pesar de ello, el crecimiento ha sido
tal que hoy su pib per cápita en
paridad de poder adquisitivo,
esto es teniendo en cuenta los
diferentes niveles de precios,
es equivalente, ojo, al de Colombia, Brasil o
Tailandia.
¡Ahí es nada!
En este caso, la clave del
éxito, como ya vimos, se encuentra en la
fortaleza de sus instituciones, en la
prudencia presupuestaria y en la
seguridad jurídica.
De hecho, en el último Índice de
Percepción de la Corrupción, Botsuana
aparece en el puesto 31, una posición
mejor que la de España, Israel o Taiwán.
- "Reformas regulatorias, buen gobierno,
todo ello es muy importante porque la
gente debe poder abrir un negocio y enviar
sus mercancías sin que nadie le pida
un soborno o tener que contratar al
primo de alguien".
Pero, ¿quieres más
sorpresas? Bien, en este continente ya hay
más de cuatrocientas empresas que
facturan cada año más de mil millones
de dólares.
Aquí, además, atentos podemos encontrar
Nollywood, la segunda industria
cinematográfica más importantes del
mundo en volumen de películas
producidas cada año. Con más de 2.500
títulos sólo se sitúa tras Bollywood,
y da empleo en Nigeria a cerca de un
millón de personas.
Y,  por cierto,
África es el líder mundial en lo que a
banca digital y pagos móviles
se refiere. Y a pesar de lo que podríamos
imaginarnos, la penetración móvil es de
más del 70 por ciento y casi cinco de
cada seis habitantes son usuarios de
internet. Hoy en día muchos granjeros
comparten sus conocimientos a través de
sms y en las calles de Ruanda se
utiliza Safemoto, que es algo así como
la versión ruandesa de Uber, y claro,
como hay pocos coches, pues utilizan motos
¿Te lo imaginabas? Es verdad, aún
son muchos los retos y desafíos que
África tiene por delante. Entre ellos,
consolidar el estado de derecho,
reducir la pobreza y mejorar sus
infraestructuras. Además, por supuesto, de
poner fin a deleznables dictaduras como
las de Angola, Eritrea o Guinea
Ecuatorial.
Sin embargo, todo apunta a que este
continente dormido está despertando.
Espero que este video te haya resultado
interesante. Podrás encontrar muchos más
casos de actualidad en nuestro canal de
Youtube y, también, los próximos
domingos en La Vanguardia.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.